une naissance sur 100 peut présenter des
troubles du neuro développement ou du
spectre autistique pour les repérer le
plus rapidement possible la ville et le
centre hospitalier de versailles
viennent de créer une formation spéciale
pour le personnel de la petite enfance
de la commune
j'en étais convaincu que y'avait que qui
pouvaient former les professionnels de
la petite enfance tout d'abord de la
ville de versailles qui vivent au
quotidien avec ces petits bouts qui déjà
constatait des problématiques et qui
était un peu un peu perdus vous ne savez
pas trop comment s'adapter comment faire
et et puis comment arriver à guider les
parents le plus vite et le mieux
possible vers vers les gens compétents
objectif donc donner les clés pour mieux
identifier pour ensuite mieux
accompagner environ 200 personnes vont
être formés sur 14 demi journée elle
travaille dans les crèches de la ville
ou encore au relais d'assistants
maternels la formation elle est conçue
pour être très pratique des
professionnels observent le comportement
spontané des enfants dans les différents
temps de la crèche par exemple à
l'entrée dans la salle motricité on du
repas du change etc mais aussi qu'ils
puissent est actif dans l'observation en
mettant en place des petits temps de jeu
que les troubles d'une re développement
ont leurs repères lorsque certaines
compétences sont mises en défaut par
rapport au calendrier habituel d'une re
développement de l'enfant la
municipalité et le centre hospitalier de
versailles souhaite également mettre en
place une prise en charge des enfants et
des parents
une première qui pourrait être étendu
dans d'autres villes du département